Hi. Welcome back.
When I started these sessions on market
timing, I called them the impossible
dream. Kind of gave away my biases
there, arguing that it's really, really
difficult to win at market timing.
This session I want to focus on the odds
of winning in market timing, why people
continue to try it, and how it might
work for some people in the market.
The evidence in market timing, as I
said, is everybody does it.
If you're a mutual fund manager, the way
you do it might be in how much cash you
hold in your portfolio. If you're an
investment newsletter, it might show up
in the words you use to describe the
market, the bullish or bearish views.
Market strategists who work at
investment banks start up every year,
give you their market timing views by
telling you what they think the market
will do over the next year relative to
holding your money in cash or in bonds.
Everybody does it. But do they do it
well? Can it actually make money for
them? Let's start with mutual fund
managers.
As I said, equity mutual fund managers
are restricted in two ways. One is they
can only be long, not they can't sell
short, and second, they're restricted to
holding their money in equities.
That already puts you in a straight
jacket when it comes to market timing,
right? So if you think stocks are
overpriced, you have no place to go. It
you can't shift your money out of
stocks, and because you're supposed to
be investing in equities, you really
can't do much about your view on market
timing. But mutual fund managers still
find a way to time markets, and the way
they do it is in how much cash they hold
in their portfolio. So let's say you're
a mutual equity mutual fund manager with
a hundred million dollars that you're
managing.
And you're bearish about markets. You
think markets are overpriced.
You might decide to hold more cash, 20
million out of the hundred million, 25
million. The percentage of your money
that's invested in cash becomes an
indirect proxy for what you think about
markets.
But does it actually predict markets? If
you can observe what mutual fund
managers hold in cash,
is there any evidence that mutual fund
managers are good market timers? In this
graph, in the columns, you see the
amount of cash that equity mutual fund
managers hold. And across time, you can
already see that cash as a percentage of
assets has decreased pretty
substantially from the 1980s and 90s
down to today. Part of that might be a
reflection of a bull market that's
lasted a long time. But you look at the
correlation between changes in cash
holdings and stock returns, the
correlation is close to zero.
There is zero information in what mutual
fund managers seem to do with cash and
what happens to markets in subsequent
periods.
In effect, if mutual fund managers are
good market timers, it's sure not
showing up in the cash holdings every
year.
There's a subset of mutual funds
that actually pride themselves in the
market timing.
They're called tactical asset allocation
funds. In theory, here's what they
promise their clients. If you put your
money with us,
we will invest a lot in stocks when we
think stocks are going up, but if we
think a bear market is coming, a
correction is coming, we'll pull your
money out of stocks.
So in this graph,
there's actually a comparison between
what tactical asset allocation funds
have earned versus a 60/40 portfolio.
You're saying, "What's a 60/40
portfolio?" 60% of money goes in stocks,
40% in bonds. It's the actual opposite
of market timing. It's a very widely
used default proxy for what investors
should do.
You know what? In the four years here,
out of the four four good years for
markets,
the 60/40 portfolio beat the tactical
asset allocation funds. You're saying,
"That's to be expected in good years."
No, but just putting your money in
stocks works.
But let's take the bad year, because
remember the promise of tactical asset
allocation is they're going to save you
money in the bad years. Turns out they
didn't save you much.
There have been much more extended
studies of tactical asset allocation
funds or mutual funds that try to time
markets. The evidence is in the long
term, there is zero evidence
that these tactical asset allocation
funds generate enough returns for their
investors to cover
the fact that they're out of markets for
extended periods.
Let's move on to hedge funds.
The view in markets is that hedge fund
managers are smarter than the rest of
us. And there's a subset of hedge funds,
not all of them, a subset, that try to
time markets, that do asset allocation
based on markets.
And the studies that have looked at
hedge funds find some evidence, though
it's not overwhelming, that this market
timing generates higher returns.
Let's be very clear, though.
The returns we're talking about is not
double the returns of an average
investor. You add a couple of percent.
Now, that also requires these hedge
funds to not just trade a lot, but in
order to to trade frequently, but have
higher transactions costs. And we factor
in that as a client in these hedge
funds,
you got to pay them two and 20, and we
talked about this earlier.
I'm not sure it covers the payoff to
market timing.
Now, so when you look at hedge funds,
and that's that are much better timing
markets,
their success seems to come from the
fact that they adjust their holdings of
equities ahead of major liquidity
changes. When markets are going to get
more illiquid, they manage to get out a
little faster than everybody else. It'd
be interesting to see updates of these
studies to see if it's held up as the
hedge fund business has become bigger
and has more capital. But at least the
early studies seem to indicate some
evidence of market timing.
What about investment newsletters? Here
again, there's a glimmer of hope.
There are some, you know,
investment newsletters that claim to
forecast what the market will do. And
there is some evidence that it works,
but the returns earned is, you know,
compared to a buy and hold strategy, a
lot of those newsletters fail. 180 out
of the 237 newsletters that were
examined in early study delivered lower
returns than buy and hold.
And the weights they they delivered, uh,
you know, for those
in those cases
were about the same before market
upturns and downturns. So, in fact, they
suggested that your equity weight be 58%
before a market upturn, but it wasn't
that much different before a market
downturn.
So, they're market timers are sure are
hiding it in the recommendations they
pass out. And one of the scarier thing
about investment newsletters
is the bad market timers stay bad.
And often people continue to subscribe
to those newsletters. Maybe they share
the same conspiracy theories about or
views about why markets are low. But bad
investment bad market timing investment
newsletters continue to stay bad and
continue to hold on to their readers.
As I said, there's some a glimmer of
hope that some of these newsletters do
deliver good advice. Some of it might
be, if you cover enough investment
newsletters, there are 500 or 1,000
investment newsletters, purely by luck a
few are going to beat the market. But
there is mild evidence of market timing.
And, you know, if you look across both
short but the catch is it requires
frequent and short-term trading.
So, basically, you make 1 or 2% more
than somebody who just holds a buy and
hold strategy or a 60/40.
But if you have to trade 100 times a
year or 200 times a year, your
transactions cost are going to wipe out
those excess returns. So, here's the
bottom line. Mutual funds, no evidence
of market timing. Hedge funds, some
evidence of market timing, but if you
factor in the costs you face as a client
in these hedge funds,
those excess returns disappear.
Investment newsletters, a few of them
seem to have some market timing, but
they require such frequent trading
that by the time you factor in the
transactions cost, no benefits remain.
Finally, let's talk about market
strategies.
Many of the major investment banks have
market strategies. They're pretty high
profiles. You see them on CNBC talking
about the right blend of stocks and
bonds and cash to have in future
periods.
This graph from the Wall Street Journal,
they compared the very best market
strategies to what you'd have earned on
a robot plan, like a 60/40 blend or a
100% equity blend.
The very best market strategies does
beat a robot plan, but a fairer
comparison
is what the average market strategist
does versus the robot plant.
And guess what?
The average market strategist seems to
add no value to the process. It's kind
of scary if you think about how much
press they get and how much news they
generate when they when they release
their recommendations or views on the
markets
to the public.
So, overall, when you look at the
evidence on market timing, it's pretty
weak to non-existent that there have
been consistent market timers.
One final aspect of the time we live in
is what we call finfluencers. What are
finfluencers? These are people who
don't have newsletters in the
traditional sense, are not market
strategies, but they have big followings
on social media, on YouTube, on TikTok,
on Instagram.
In fact, in this graph, you look at
which looked at these finfluencers, and
it's still early in the game, and where
they go, you can see how many of them
are on TikTok versus YouTube and
Instagram. The The differences seem to
be on um
uh uh,
on YouTube, there are far more people
who are promoting things, trying to sell
you stuff.
You have a little more guidance from
from TikTok and Instagram for
influencers. Again, very early studies,
but clearly the mix of people on the
different platforms seems to yield very
different views on what they bring, what
they're trying to do.
So, as you look at a finfluencer, one of
the first places to look at is what
platform are they using and what are
they trying to do? Are they trying to
promote something? Are they trying to
make a recommendation? Are they trying
to provide provide investment guidance?
And if you look at how well they do at
market timing and predicting the market,
it's still early in the game. Okay?
Now, many of them still focus on meme
stocks, so there's this insane amount of
following that you get if you pick a
meme stock or on cryptos, where again,
you get following.
And they've been lucky. They've been
lucky in the sense they've been in a
period where equity markets have for the
most part gone up. Bitcoin has gone up
in a hundredfold over the last decade.
And it's easy to look good when markets
are doing well. The test of market
timing is when you're under duress, and
many of these finfluencers have not been
in a market under duress.
And my prediction is that when there is
a market under duress, you're going to
see some shaking up, that you're going
to separate the wheat from the chaff
here. And it's coming because, you know,
it
If you look at much of the advice, it's
shallow, it's based on not facts, but
opinions. It's it's it's a very very
it's a very mixed, very volatile place
to be in terms of getting investment
advice.
So, as an investor, you know, given all
of the things we've said about market
timing, you can choose not to time
markets and stay away from saying, "It's
not for me. I can't do it." But if you
decide to bring market timing into your
portfolio into your investment game,
there are four ways you can do it.
One is you can adjust your adjust your
asset allocation
to reflect your views on markets, right?
And we all do it, I think, implicitly
even when we claim we don't.
The second is to switch sectors or
styles based on where you think the
market is going. What I
mean by that earlier on as we talked
about different investment philosophies,
we talked about how some philosophies do
well in certain types of markets. And
maybe if you're a market timer, you
might be able to take advantage of those
shifts over time.
And finally, you can go all in and say,
"Look, I'm a market timer. I'm going to
bet on market timing and
essentially try to make your money on
just making big bets on market
direction."
Let's start with the asset allocation
changes.
Asset allocation changes, as I said, you
start with an asset allocation mix that
reflects your views on risk aversion,
your age, your liquidity needs.
And you can then you bring your market
timing to adjust that asset allocation
away from what you'd have picked if you
didn't have market timing views.
Put simply, if your if your
risk aversion would have led you to 50%
stocks, 50% bonds, but you think stocks
are cheap and bonds are expensive, you
might put 80% in stocks and 20% in
bonds.
The extreme version of this is you go
100% into those assets that you think
are underpriced and 0% stocks are
overpriced.
But that's an asset allocation change.
Second is is style switching.
If you remember our conversation on
value versus growth investing, and we
looked at the year-to-year difference,
while over the long term, low PE stocks
have beat high PE stocks, in extended
stretches where high PE stocks did
better. And then you dig a little deeper
and you look at when that happens, it
turns out that both small cap and growth
investing do much better when growth is
low.
And the yield curve is downward sloping.
You're saying, "So what?"
You might think your competitive
advantage is forecasting when growth is
going to be low. So maybe you're good at
doing that. And if you can do that, then
you can pick a philosophy that'll do
well
when growth is low, which would be
growth and small cap investing. One
study that looked at investor with
perfect foresight, basically switching
between and growth stocks just ahead of
those shifts that you saw in that
long-term graph of value versus growth,
you know, not surprisingly, would have
you would have earned much higher
returns than somebody who couldn't have
made that switch.
So if you're a good market timer, the
second way this might play out rather
than through asset allocation is what
kinds of stocks you own. So if you think
stocks are going to go up, you might
shift to value stocks. But if you think
stocks are going to be, you know, you're
going to you know, be in low growth
period, you might shift to growth
stocks. And that might make you higher
returns over time because you got the
timing right.
This is a graph that's a throwback to
the last century. In the last century,
in fact, if you looked at US equity
markets, it followed a very tight script
where sectors actually rotated through
as the market went up and down. So
certain sectors did well when you're in
a in a full recession, certain sectors
jumped on the bandwagon fast in early
recovering.
And if you buy into this sector cycle,
here's what you're going to do.
You're essentially going to use your
views on the market and the economy to
sector shift. Shifting out of cyclicals
to industrial to energy to services to
finance. And now, of course, you got to
bring technology into the mix and look
at which sectors do well and what types
of markets. Again, a version of market
timing showing up less in asset
allocation
or even in style and more in what sector
does you own in your portfolio.
And finally, of course, you can
speculate. If you're If you really have
enough confidence in your market timing,
you can go out and make a bet on it.
It's a high-risk, high-return strategy,
as we saw at the very in a very
introductory session, the reason people
are drawn to market timing is if you can
do it right, you're going to do much
better than somebody who picks stocks.
The high-risk, high-return strategy. And
if you can pull it off, I mean, that's
you know, you're going to look much
better than investors who are picking
individual stocks.
And of course, you could put this entire
strategy on steroids if you use
leverage, by either borrowing money to
buy stocks if you think stocks are
underpriced, or buying call options,
which is essentially the equivalent,
right? Because because you're
effectively using leverage. Either way,
you're making a bet on your market
timing being right and taking And as I
said, high-risk, high-return.
So, let's summarize.
Market timing
it draws people because of the huge
payoff you get if you're right.
Everybody does it. Even people who claim
not to do it. Some do it subtly by
changing the amount of cash they have in
their portfolio. Some are explicit,
actually bet on market timing.
With all that said, though, history's
not been kind to market timers. In what
sense?
If you look at the 100 years plus that
we have information about markets and
who's been playing on markets,
it's very difficult to point to people
who've been consistently successful with
market timing.
In fact, every correction or big move up
brings market gurus to the surface.
These are people who got that big move
right, but if you track them over time,
they're more like shooting stars. They
don't seem to survive the next cycle.
With all of that said, though, it's a
choice you have to make of how much
market timing you want to bring into
your portfolio analysis. And remember,
don't make it an either/or. You can be
both a stock picker and a market timer.
And often, you can have the same
philosophy driving both. If you're an
intrinsic value person, you might say,
"I will buy stocks because they're cheap
on an intrinsic value base." And you
would bring that same perspective to
markets. The same views you have about
markets overreacting or learning slowly
can drive both your market timing and
your security selection.
The two caveats I would have is
if you have different skills as a stock
picker and a market timer, it behooves
you to keep track of how good you are at
either. Cuz if you're really good at one
and not that good at at the other, you
need to know where your where your where
your differential advantage lies. And if
you find that your attempts at one are
undercutting the other, let's say that
you're a great stock picker, but in
trying to time markets, you're actually
hurting yourself.
You might want to abandon the market
timing component of the philosophy and
focus just on the stock picking.
Being aware of what works and doesn't
work for you is a key step in financing
and fine-tuning your investment
philosophy.
I hope you found the session useful, and
I thank you very much for listening.